The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TOM MITCHELL: I want
to talk about some work
that we're doing to try to
study language in the brain.
Actually, to be honest, this
is part of a grander plan.
So here is what I'm really
doing with my research life.
I'm interested in
language, and so I'm
involved in two different
research projects.
One of them is to build a
computer to learn to read.
And we have a project
which we call our Never
Ending Language Learner,
which is an attempt
to build a computer program
to learn to read the web.
NELL, we call it, has been
running nonstop, 24 hours a day
since 2010.
So it's now five years old.
If you have very
good eyesight, you
can tell that everybody's
t-shirt there in the group
is wearing a NELL fifth
birthday party t-shirt.
But it's an effort
to try to understand
what it would be like to
build a computer program that
runs forever and gets
better every day.
In this case, its job is
to learn to read the web.
It is getting better.
It currently has about
100 million beliefs
that it has read from the web.
It's learning to infer new
beliefs from old beliefs.
It's a better reader today
than it was last year.
It was better last year
than it was the year before.
It's still not anything like
as competent as you and I,
but it's one line
of research that you
can follow if you're interested
in understanding language
understanding.
The other thread,
which is what I'm
going to talk about tonight,
which is in the bottom half
here, is to study how the
brain processes language
by putting people
in brain imaging
scanners of different types, and
showing them language stimuli,
and getting them to read.
So I'm going to focus
really on the bottom part.
But I can't really talk
about this honestly
unless I fess up to the fact
that my goal is for these two
projects to collide in
a monstrous collision.
They haven't yet, although
you'll see some signs,
I hope, tonight, of some
of the cross-fertilisation
between the two areas.
When it comes to the
brain imaging work,
we have a very great
team of people.
One of them, Nicole Rafidi,
is sitting right here.
Some of you have already
met her this week.
And so what I'm going to
present is really the group work
of quite a few people.
And the idea is simple,
but here's the brainteaser.
Suppose you're interested in how
the brain processes language,
and you have access to some
scanning machines, then
what would you do?
And so we started
out by showing people
in a scanner stimuli like these.
Maybe single words, initially
nouns like camera, and drill,
and house, and saw.
Sometimes pictures, sometimes
pictures with words under them.
But just showing people
stimuli to get them
to think about some concept.
And then we collect
a brain image,
like this one,
which we collected
when a person was looking
at this particular stimulus,
a bottle.
And this is posterior, this is
the back of the head on top.
This is the front of the
head at the bottom here.
And these four slices are
four out of about 22 slices
of the brain that make up
the three dimensional image.
And so you can see here what
the brain activity looks like--
kind of blotchy-- when one
particular person thinks about,
bottle.
So you might ask, what
does it look like if they
think about something else?
Well, I can show you what it
looks like on the average.
If we average over
60 different words,
then here's the brain activity.
And you can see that it
looks a lot like bottle,
but maybe there are
some differences.
And in fact if I subtract
out this mean activity
from the brain image
we get for bottle,
then you can see
the residue here.
There are in fact
some differences
in the activity we see
for bottle compared
to the mean activity
over many words.
Whether that's
signal or noise, I
guess you can't tell by
looking at this picture.
But that's the kind
of data that we have
if we use fMRI to capture
brain activity while people
read words.
So the first thing
you might think
of doing if you had
this kind of data
would be to train a
machine learning program
to decode from these brain
images which word somebody is
thinking about it.
And so we, in fact, began that
way by training classifiers
where we'd give
them a brain image.
And during training
time we would tell them
which word that brain
image corresponds to.
And then after training we
could test the classifier
to see whether
indeed it had learned
the right pattern of activity
by showing it new brain images
and having it tell us, for
example, is this person reading
the word hammer or bottle.
And, in fact, that works
that works quite well.
And, in fact, if you try it over
several different participants
in our study, you can see we
get classification accuracies
for a Boolean
classification problem.
Are they reading a tool word
like hammer, saw, chisel,
or a building were like
house, palace, hotel.
Then, depending on
the individual person,
we can get in the high 90%
accuracy or a little worse.
In fact, if you ask why it's
not the same for all people,
it turns out the accuracy
that we get correlates
very well with measure of
head motion in the machine.
So a lot of this is noise.
But the bottom
line here is good.
fMRI actually has
enough resolution
to resolve the differences in
neural activity between, say,
thinking about
house versus hammer.
And machine learning methods
can discover those distinctions.
So that's a good basis.
And so given that, you
can start asking a number
of interesting questions.
Like we could ask, well,
what about you and me?
Do we have the same
pattern of brain activity
to encode hammer, and house,
and all the other concepts?
Or do each of us do
something different?
And we can convert that into
a machine learning question,
right?
We could say, well, what
if we train on people
on that side of the room.
We'll collect their brain
data and train our program.
Then we'll collect
data from these people
and try to decode
which word they're
reading based on
the patterns that we
learned from those people.
If that works, then that's
overwhelming evidence
that we have very similar neural
encodings of different word
meanings.
So we tried that and,
in fact, it works.
In fact, here you see in
black, the accuracies,
just like on the first slide,
of how well we can decode
which word a person
is reading in black,
If we train on data from the
same person we're testing on.
But in white you
see the accuracies
we get if we train on no
data at all from this person,
but instead train
on the data from all
the other participants.
And you see on average
we do about as well
with the white bars as we
do with the black bars.
In fact, in some cases
we do better training
on other people.
That might be, for
example, because we get
to use more training examples.
We get to use all the other
participants' data instead
of just one participant's data.
But again, the
important thing here
is, this is very strong evidence
that, even though we're all
very different people,
we have remarkably
similar neural encodings when
we think about common nouns.
Which is something that
really, say in the year 2000,
I don't think
anybody understood.
So I want to kind of
wrap up this idea.
So I want to go through
basically four ideas
in this talk.
Idea number one
is, gee, we could
train classifiers to try to
decode from the neural activity
which word a person is reading.
And if we do that,
then we can actually
ask some interesting
scientific questions,
like are the patterns
similar across our brains?
Does it depend whether
it's a picture or a word?
And, in fact, we can think
of this technique of training
and classifier as--
the way I think of it
is it's a way of building a
virtual sensor of information
content in the neural signal.
So I think that fMRI
was truly a revolution
in the study of the brain,
because for the first time
we could look inside
and see the activity.
But I think these classifiers
give us a different thing.
Now we can look inside and see
not just the neural activity,
but the information encoded
in that neural activity.
And so it's a different
kind of sensor.
And you can design your
own and train it, and then
use it to study
information represented
in the neural
signal in the brain.
So it kind of opens
up a very large set
of methods, and techniques,
and experiments that we can now
run with brain imaging.
Where instead of looking
just at the activity,
we now can look at the
information content.
OK, so that's idea number one.
We were quite pleased
with ourselves
and we are doing this work.
But in the back of
back of our mind
was kind of a gnawing question
of, well, this is good,
now maybe we've trained on
a couple of hundred words,
so we have a couple hundred
different neural patterns
of activity.
We have kind of a list
of the neural codes
for a couple of hundred
words, but that's not really
a theory of neural
encodings of meaning.
It's a list.
What would it mean
to have a theory?
Well, scientific theories
are logical systems
that can make predictions.
And if they're
interesting theories,
they make experimentally
testable predictions.
So in our case,
it would be nice,
if we want to study
representations of meaning,
to have a theory where we
could input an arbitrary noun
and get it to
predict for us what
would be the neural
representation for that non.
At least that would
be better than a list.
That would be a generative
theory or model.
And so we're interested in this.
And we worked on this for
a while and came up with--
our first version of
this looked like this.
It's a computational
model that was trained.
And once it's
trained, it would make
a prediction for any input word,
like telephone, in two steps.
Step one, if you gave it a word
like telephone, for example.
Step one, it would look
up the word telephone
in a trillion words of
text collected from the web
and represent that word
by a set of statistics
about how telephone is used.
In our case,
statistics about which
verbs co-occurred
with that noun.
And then in the
second step, it would
use that vector
which approximates
the meaning of the input noun
as the basis for predicting
in each of 20,000
locations in the brain,
how much activity
will there be there.
So let me push on
that a little bit.
So I say in step one, we look
up for a word like celery which
verbs that occur with.
Well, here are the
statistics that we get.
This is normalized to
be a vector of length 1.
But you can see for celery
the most common verb is eat.
And taste is second most common.
But celery doesn't occur
very often with ride.
On the other hand,
airplane occurs a lot
with ride, and not very much
with manipulate and rub.
So these are the verb statistics
extracted from the web
for two typical nouns.
And step one of
the model was just
to collect statistics
for whatever now we
give it to make the prediction.
Step two is then to predict
at each location in the brain
what the neural activity will
be there, the fMRI activity,
as a function of those
statistics we just collected.
So for the word
celery, now we know
it occurs 0.84 with eat and
0.35 with the verb taste.
We're now going to make a
prediction of this voxel.
In particular, the
prediction that voxel v
is the sum, over those 25
verbs that we're using,
of how frequently verb i
occurs with the input noun,
celery in this case, times
some coefficient that we
have to learn from training.
And this coefficient tells
us how voxel v is influenced
by co-occurring with verb i.
And we have 25
verbs, 20,000 voxels,
so we have 500,000 of these
coefficients to learn.
We learn them by taking
nouns, collecting the brain--
the same data we use to
train those classifiers.
So we have a collection of nouns
and the corresponding brain
images.
For each of those nouns we can
look up the verbs statistics.
And then we can
train on that data
to estimate all these
half million coefficients.
When you put those coefficients
together, say, for eat,
this is actually a plot
of the coefficient values.
Here's one of those
coefficients for the verb
eat in a particular
voxel right there.
So you can think of the
coefficients associated
with each verb as forming a kind
of activity map for that verb.
And a weighted linear sum of
those verb-associated activity
maps gives us a
prediction for celery.
You could ask, how well
do these predictions work?
One way I could answer
that is to show you here,
when we trained
on 58 other nouns,
not including celery,
not including airplane.
And then we had the system
predict these novel,
to it, words.
Celery, it predicted this image.
Airplane, it
predicted this image.
Unbeknownst to it, here are
the actual observed images
for celery and airplane.
So you can see it
correctly predicts
some of this structure--
this is, by the way,
fusiform gyrus--
but not all the structure.
So it captures some
of what's going on.
I can, in a more
quantitative way,
tell you how well
it's working by--
we can test the
program this way.
We can say, here are two
words you have not seen.
Here are two images
you have not seen.
One of them is celery,
one is airplane.
You, the program, tell me which.
If it was just
working at chance,
it would get an accuracy of 50%.
If you just guess randomly,
you'll get half of those right
by chance.
In its case, averaged over
nine different subjects
in the experiment,
we get 79% accuracy.
So what does this mean?
What this means is, three
times out of four, 79%,
we could give this trained model
two new nouns that it has never
seen, two fMRI images
for those nouns,
and it could tell us three times
out of four which was which.
So this model is
extrapolating beyond the words
on which it was trained.
And it's extrapolating,
not perfectly, but somewhat
successfully to other nouns.
Now, why?
What's the basis on which
it's doing that extrapolation?
What are the assumptions
built into this model?
Well, for one
thing, it's assuming
that you can predict the neural
representation of any word
based on corpus
statistics summarizing how
that word is used on the web.
Furthermore, it's assuming
that any noun you can think of
has a neural
representation which
lives in a 25-dimensional
vector space, where
each dimension corresponds
to one of those 25 verbs.
And every image is some point
in this 25-dimensional vector
space.
That's what that
linear equation is
doing when it's combining
some weighted combination
of these 25 axes to
predict the image.
So, I don't actually
believe that everything
you think lives in a
25-dimensional space
where the dimensions
are those verbs.
But the interesting thing
is that the model works.
And so it does mean that there
is some more primitive set
of meaning components out of
which these neural patterns are
being constructed.
It's not just a big hash
code where every word
gets its own pattern.
If that were the
case, we wouldn't
be able to extrapolate
and predict
new ones by adding together
these different 25 components.
So patterns are
being built up out
of more primitive
semantic components.
And this model is
crudely, only 79%,
capturing some of
that substructure that
gets combined when you
think about an entire word.
And the substructure are the
different meaning components.
The point here, I
think, is, here's
a model that's different
from training a classifier.
This is actually a
generative model.
It can make predictions that
extrapolate beyond the training
words on which it was trained.
It is assuming that there is
a space of semantic primitives
out of which the patterns of
neural activity are built.
And it is assuming that that
space is at least spanned
by the corpus
statistics of the noun.
And since then, we've
extended this work,
and we no longer use just
that list of 25 verbs.
We actually use a very high
100-million-dimensional vector,
which is generally
very sparse, but where
every feature comes from a
much more precise parse of text
on the web.
And for example,
when I say parse,
I mean if we have
a simple sentence
like, he booked a ticket, this
would be a dependency parse.
It's showing, for
example, that booked
is a verb whose subject is
he and whose direct object
is ticket.
And now each of these
edges in the parse
becomes a feature in our new
representation of the word.
So instead of using verbs, we
use dependency parse features.
And this actually increases
slightly the accuracy
of our former model
from 79 up a little bit.
But importantly, it also lets us
work with all parts of speech.
So now we're not restricted
to just using nouns.
We can use these dependency
parse vectors for adjectives
and all parts of speech.
So in terms of
broadening the model
to be able to handle
different types of words,
this is helpful.
So at this point you
could say, well, this
is kind of interesting,
because what have we seen?
I think the main
points so far are, gee,
different people have
very similar patterns
of neural activity that their
brains use to encode meaning.
Furthermore, those
patterns of neural activity
decompose into more primitive
semantic components.
And we can train models that
extrapolate to new words
on which they weren't trained
by learning those more
primitive semantic
components and how
to combine them for novel words
based on corpus statistics.
So that's kind of interesting.
But everything that
I've said so far
is really about the static
spatial distribution
of neural activity that
encodes these things.
Now, in truth, your
neural activity
is not just one little snapshot.
When you understand a word--
do you know how long it
takes you to understand a word?
About 400 milliseconds.
It takes about 400 milliseconds
to understand a word.
Well, it turns out there is
interesting brain activity
dynamics during those
400 milliseconds.
And let me show you.
So up till now, we were
looking at fMRI data.
But here's some
magnetoencephalography data.
And this data has a time
resolution of one millisecond.
So I'll show you
this movie which
begins 20 milliseconds before
a word appears on the screen.
In this case, the
word is the word hand.
And this brain is about
to read the word hand.
You'll see 550 milliseconds
of brain activity.
I'll read out the
numbers so you can just
watch the activity over here.
So here we go.
20 milliseconds before the
word appears on the screen.
0, 100, 200 milliseconds,
300, 400 milliseconds, 500.
OK, so it wasn't a static
snapshot of activity.
Your brain is doing
a lot of things.
There's a lot of dynamism
during that 400 milliseconds
that you're reading the word.
fMRI captures an image
about once a second,
but because of the
blood oxygen level
dependent mechanism that it
uses to capture that, it's
kind of smeared out over time.
So we can't see this dynamics
with fMRI, but with MEG we can.
And so now we can ask all
kinds of interesting questions,
like well, what was
the information encoded
in that movie that we just saw?
I just showed you a
movie of neural activity,
but I want a movie of
data flow in the brain.
I want the movie showing
me what information
is encoded over time.
Given this data,
what could we do?
Well, here's one
thing we can do.
In fact, Gus Sudre did
this for his PhD thesis.
He said, I want to know
what information is flowing
around the brain
there, so I'm going
to train roughly a million
different classifiers.
I'll train classifiers that
look at just 100 milliseconds
worth of that movie and
look at just one of 70
or so anatomically
defined brain regions.
And I'll use a set
of features-- he
wasn't using our verbs anymore.
He was using a set
of 229 features
that we had made up manually
and that were inspired
by the game 20 questions.
These were features
of the word, not
like, how often does a court
does it co-occur with the verb
eat?
But instead, features
like, would you eat it?
Yes or no.
Is it bigger than a bread box?
And so forth.
He had a set of 218
questions like that.
And every word
could be described
by a set of 218 answers
to those questions,
analogous to the verbs.
And so what Gus did is, for
every one of those features,
every one of those
218 features like,
is it bigger than a breadbox,
he trained a classifier
to try to decode the
value of that for the word
that you're reading from
just 100 milliseconds
worth of this movie, and
looking at just one of 70
anatomically defined regions.
And so when he did
that, he ended up
being able to make us a movie
of what information is coded,
in which part of
the brain, when.
And he ran this--
every 50 milliseconds
he'd move forward and use a
100 millisecond window starting
there.
So he found that during
the first 50 milliseconds
after the word
appears on the screen,
none of those classifiers
could reliably,
in a cross validated
way, produce
any reliable predictions.
Meaning the neural
signals seems to not
encode any of those
semantic features
during the first
50 milliseconds.
By timing out to
100 milliseconds,
there were no semantic features,
but you could decode things
like the number of letters
in the word, the word length.
At 150 milliseconds,
at 200 milliseconds,
you got the first
semantic feature.
Is it hairy?
I think this is actually a
stand-in for, is it alive?
But the feature he happened
to uncover was, is it hairy?
At 200 milliseconds.
At 250, now we start to
see more semantic features.
300, 350, 400, 450.
So literally, these are the
semantic features trickling
in over time during
this 500 milliseconds--
that's the movie--
that corresponds to
the neural activity
that I showed you
in that first movie.
So this is a kind of data flow
picture of what information
is flowing around in the
brain in that neural activity
during that 450
milliseconds so far.
Here's the set.
Out of those 218 questions,
here are the 20 most decodable
features.
So the number one feature
that's most decodable,
is that bigger than
a loaf of bread?
But actually, if you
look at those questions,
you see many of the
most incredible ones
are really size.
And many of the next
are manipulability.
And many others are animacy.
And some are shelter.
In fact, we've across a
diverse set of experiments
keep seeing these
kind of features.
Size, manipulability,
animacy, shelter,
edibility are recurring as
features that have their own--
they seem to be kind
of naturally some
of the primitive components.
And they have their
corresponding neural
signatures, out of which the
encoding of the full word
is built.
So if you ask me
right now, what's
my best guess of what are
the semantic primitives out
of which the neural
codes are built, I'd say,
I don't really know.
But these features plus
edibility, for example,
keep recurring in
what we're seeing.
And they have their
own spatial regions
where the codes seem to live.
OK, so I want to get to
the final part, which
is, so far we've talked
about just single words.
And there's plenty of
interesting questions
we can ask about single words.
But really, language is
about multiple words.
And so I want to show you a
couple of examples of some more
recent work where we've been
looking at semantic composition
with the adjective-noun phrases.
This is the work of Alona Fyshe.
And what she did is
she presented people
with just simple
adjective-noun sequences.
She put an adjective on
the screen like tasty,
leave it there
for half a second,
then a noun like tomato.
And she was interested
in the question of,
well, where and when is the
neural encoding of these two
words, and what does
that encoding look like?
So I'll show you a
couple of things.
One is, here is a picture
of the classifier weights
that were learned to
decode the adjective.
And you have to
think of it this way.
Here's time.
And this is the time, the
first 500 milliseconds
when the adjectives
on the screen.
Then there's 300
milliseconds of dead air.
Then 500 milliseconds when
the noun is on the screen.
And then more dead air.
This, the vertical axis,
are different locations
in the sensor helmet
of the MEG scanner.
And there are
about 306 of those.
The intensity here
is showing the weight
of a trained classifier
that was trained
to decode the adjective.
And, in fact, this
is the pattern
of activity associated
with the adjective gentle.
Like gentle bear.
And so what you see here is
that there is neural activity
out here when the
noun is on the screen
long after the adjective has
disappeared from the screen.
That's quite
relevant to decoding
what the adjective was.
And so this is just
kind of a quick look.
You can see that if I say
tasty tomato, even when
you're reading the word tomato,
there's neural activity here,
when you're looking at
that noun, that encodes
what the adjective had been.
And we can see
that, in fact, it's
a different pattern
of neural activity
than was here when
the adjective was on.
And in fact, one thing that
Alona got interested in
is, given that you
can decode across time
what that adjective
was, is your brain
using the same neural
encoding across time?
Or is it a different
neural encoding, maybe
for different
purposes across time.
Let me explain what she did.
She trained a
classifier at one time
in this time series
of adjective-noun,
and then she would test it
at some other time point.
And if you could
train at this time,
like let's say, right when the
adjective comes on the screen,
and use it successfully
to decode the adjective
way down here when the
noun is on the screen,
then we can know that it's
the same neural encoding,
because that's what it's doing.
And then she made a plot,
a two-dimensional plot,
where you could plot, let's
say, the time at which you train
the classifier on
the vertical axis,
and the time at which you test
it on the horizontal axis.
And then we could show at
each training test time
whether you could
train at this time
and then decode at this time.
And that'll tell
us whether there's
a stable neural encoding of the
adjective meaning across time.
When she did that, here's
what it looks like.
OK, so here we have
on the vertical axis
the time at which she trained.
This is when the adjective is
on the screen, the first 500
milliseconds, when the
noun's on the screen.
Here's then using any of
these trained classifiers
for decoding the adjective.
Here's a different time at
which she tried to use it.
And again, here's
when the adjective's
on the screen, the noun.
And so what you see--
all this intense stuff means
high decoding accuracy--
shows that if you train when
the adjective is on the screen,
you can use that to decode other
times at which the adjective's
on the screen.
That's good.
So we can decode adjectives.
But if you try to use it to
decode the adjective when
the noun's on the
screen, it fails.
Blue means failure.
No statistically significant
decoding accuracy.
On the other hand, when
the noun is on the screen
if you train using the
neural patterns when
the nouns on the
screen, then you
can, in fact, decode
what the adjective
had been while the
noun is on the screen.
So it's like there are
two different encodings
of the adjective
being used here.
One when the adjective's
on the screen that lets you
successfully decode it when
the adjective's on the screen,
but it doesn't work when
the noun's on the screen.
And then the second one that
works another neural encoding
that you can use to decode
what the adjective had been
when the noun is on the screen.
And then interestingly, there's
also this other region here,
which says if you train when
the adjective was on the screen,
you can't use that to
successfully decode it
when the noun's on the screen.
But later on, when nothing is on
the screen, the phrase is gone,
your brain is still
thinking about the adjective
in a way that's using this
neural encoding, the very first
of those neural encodings.
This is evidence that the neural
encoding of the adjective that
was present when you
saw the adjective
is re-emerging now a
couple seconds later,
after that thing
is off the screen.
But the neural encoding
of the adjective
when the noun was on the screen
doesn't seem to get used again.
Most recently, we've
also been looking
at stories and passages.
And much of this,
not all of it, is
the work of Leila Wehbe,
another PhD student.
And here's what she did.
She put people in fMRI
and in MEG scanners,
and she showed them the
following kind of stimulus.
So this goes on for
about 40 minutes.
One chapter of a
Harry Potter story.
And word by word,
every 500 milliseconds,
we know exactly when
you've seen every word.
So she collected this
data in fMRI and in MEG
to try to study the
jumble of activity that
goes on in your
brain when you're
reading not an isolated
word, but a whole story.
And so for her, with the fMRI we
get an image every two seconds.
So four words go by and
we get an fMRI image.
So here's the kind
of data that she had.
She trained a model that's
very analogous to the very
first generative model I
talked about where we would
input a word, code
it with verbs,
and then use that to
predict neural activity.
In her case, she took an
approach where for every word,
she would encode that word
with a big feature vector.
And that vector could
summarize both the meaning
of the individual
word, but it also
could have other
features that capture
the context or the various
properties of the story
at that point in time.
But the general framework
was to convert the time
series of words into a time
series of feature vectors
that capture individual
word meanings plus story
content at that time, and then
to use that to predict the fMRI
and MEG activity.
So when she did
this, here are some
of the kind of features
that we ended up using.
So some of there were like
motions of the characters,
like was there somebody flying--
this was the Harry Potter story.
Somebody manipulating,
or moving,
or physically colliding.
What were the emotions
being experienced
by the characters in the
story that you're focused
on at this point in time?
What were the parts of
speech of the different words
and other syntactic features.
What were the semantic content?
We also used the
dependency parse statistics
that I mentioned that capture
semantics of individual words.
So altogether, she had a feature
vector with about 200 features.
Some manually annotated, some
captured by corpus statistics.
And for every word
in the story we
then had this feature vector.
Then she trained this
model that literally
would take as input a sequence
of words, convert that
into the feature
sequence, and then,
using the trained
regression, predict
the time series
of brain activity
from those feature vectors.
So this allowed
her to then test,
analogous to what we did with
our single word noun generative
model, to test to see, did the
model learn well enough that we
could give it to different
passages, and then
one real time series
of observed data,
and ask it to tell us
which passage this person
was reading.
And these would be novel
passages that were not
part of the training data.
And she found that it was, in
fact, possible, imperfectly,
but three times out of four,
to take a passage which
was not part of--
two passages which had
never been seen in training,
and a time series of
neural activity never seen
during training, and
three times out of four,
tell us which of those two
passages they correspond to.
So capturing some of
the structure here.
Interestingly, as a
side effect of that,
you end up with a map of
different cortical regions
and which of these 200
features are encoded
in different cortical regions.
So from one analysis
of people reading
this very complicated, complex
story, in this analysis,
we end up--
you can go [AUDIO OUT]
features and color code.
Some of them have to do
with syntax, like part
of speech and sentence length.
Some have to do
with dialogue, some
have to do visual properties
or characters in the stories.
And you can see here
is a map of where
those different
types of information
were decodable from
the neural activity.
Interestingly, here is a
slightly earlier piece of work,
from Ev Fedorenko showing where
there is neural activity that's
selectively associated
with language processing.
The difference here is
that in Leila's work,
she was also able to
indicate not just where
the activity was, but what
information is encoded there.
And then again, you can
drill down on some of these.
If you want know
more about syntax,
we could actually look at
the different syntax features
and see, well, where's the
part of speech encoded?
What about the length
of the sentence?
What about the specific
dependency role
in the parse of the
word that we're reading
right now, and so forth.
So this gives us a
way then of starting
to look simultaneously at very
complex cognitive function,
right?
You're reading a story,
you're perceiving the words,
you're figuring out
what part of speech,
you're parsing the sentence.
You're thinking about
the plot, you're
fitting this into the plot.
You're feeling sorry
for the hero who
just had their brooms stolen,
and all kinds of stuff
going on in your head.
Here's the analysis that
attempts to simultaneously
analyze a diverse range
of these features,
and I think with some success.
There still remain
problems of correlations
between different features.
And so it might be hard
to know whether we're
decoding the fact that
somebody is being shouted at,
versus the fact that their
ears are hurting, so to speak.
But there could be two
different properties we thinking
of that are highly correlated.
And so it can still be
hard to tease those apart.
But I think that, to me,
the interesting thing
about Leila's analysis here
is that it flips from a style
that I would call reductionist.
One way that people often
study language in the brain
is they pick one
phenomena, and then
run a carefully controlled
experiment to just vary
that one dimension.
Like we'll use
words, and we'll use
letter strings that
are pronounceable
that are not words,
and then words.
And we'll just look at
what's different in those two
almost identical situations.
Here, instead, we have
people doing natural reading,
doing a complex
cognitive function,
and try to use a
multivariate analysis
to simultaneously model all
of those different functions.
And so I think this is an
interesting, methodologically,
position to take.
And it also gives
us a chance to start
looking at some of these
phenomena in story reading.